as we entered into World War one the
British already had a presence in the
Middle East
Egypt was a already a British
protectorate and it formalized this as
as we entered into World War one and
they don't get their independence until
1922 and the British just don't hand it
to them they fight for this they have a
revolt against British rule and they win
so you have an independent Egypt in 1922
the British also had Kuwait as a
protectorate and this is from the 1800s
and they don't get their independence
until 1961 now we also know that the
British were eager to get the help of
the Arabs to essentially convince the
Arabs to revolt against the Ottomans so
that they could fight the successfully
fight the Ottomans on the Sinai and
Palestine France and on the Mesopotamia
front and in particular they tried to
convince this gentleman Hussein bin Ali
who at the time at the beginning of
World War one is the serif' of Mecca and
in order to convince him they make
promises to them you have a whole video
on the McMahan Hussein correspondence
well they say look if you help us we
will give you an independent state an
independent Arab state that would
include all of this territory except for
maybe except for maybe this region right
up here and so with those British
assurances he agrees to commit his
forces to fight in the Arab revolt to
rise up and to help the British and from
that point on in 1916 where you have the
Arab revolt he declares himself as the
king of the Hejaz
and just as a little bit of a geography
tangent right over here this is the
hedge oz it's kind of the west coast of
the Arabian Peninsula and it contains
the very influential towns of Mecca and
Medina now you might say well whatever
happened to the hedge oz is and most us
in all of this region right now Saudi
Arabia and you are correct and what
happened shortly after so in 1916 he
declares himself king of the Hejaz but
then you had another group the Saudis in
the Nejd
region which is this area right over
here so they they're able to they are
able
in 1920 in 1925 successfully
successfully successfully conquer the
nejd and you have even south who
declares himself king of the Nejd and
his jaws from 1926 to 1932 and he later
litt merges them into Saudi Arabia and
he's the first king of Saudi Arabia all
the way until 1953 so that's how you get
Saudi Arabia now let's continue let's
rewind back to World War 1 you have the
Arab revolt he who st. Benelli declares
himself the king of the Hejaz two of his
sons are very active in collaborating
with the British to fight against the
Ottomans this right over here is fassl
bin Hussein bin Hussein literally means
son of Hussein this right over here is
Abdullah and by the end of the war and
we covered this in the Sinai Palestine
and Mesopotamia campaigns the combined
British enter and Arab forces are able
to move all the way into all the way
into what is now northern Syria they're
also able to move into what is now
northern what is now northern Iraq and
you can imagine at this point the Arabs
are eager in a post post world
environment to have their state and the
reason why they're a little bit
uncertain about their future is based on
what some of the things that came out
during the war we now know that while
the British were trying to convince
Hussein bin Ali to to get his forces to
rise up against the Ottomans they were
they were dealing with the French and
the secret sykes-picot agreement to
essentially carve up this whole
territory between the British and the
French they really weren't talking about
independent States for the Arabs a few
years later in 1917 this was still
during the war while the war was
happening you have the Balfour
Declaration which declared the the
British intent to create a homeland for
the Jewish people then a month later on
really the end of that month November
1917 the Russians make the sike picot
agreement public so all of these things
made made the Arabs very uneasy they got
assurances from the British that oh you
know that wasn't that serious of an
agreement
you know just keep keep fighting with us
so at the end of the war they were eager
to get to get what they thought was
their their just claim and so you have
Faisal bin Hussein he attends the Paris
Peace Conference in 1919 so 1919 year of
the Paris Paris Peace Conference and
just to be clear at that point in time
it wasn't obvious that you necessarily
had to have this what we now have is
this conflict between what is now Israel
and the Arab people fassl bin Hussein
was actually eager to to kind of reach
out to the World Zionist Organization to
the Zionist movement to hopefully get
their help in establishing an
independent Arab state he didn't think
that they would that it would establish
an independent Jewish state but he he
said hey look if I can if I can have a
homeland here but but in order to get
that homeland they're willing to support
me for an independent Arab state that I
might kind of send out an olive branch
to them and this right over here is a
quote by fassl bin Hussein and this is
while he's trying to get support for an
independent Arab state one that he would
argue was promised to him by the McMahon
the McMahon correspondences with his
father so this is facile we Arabs look
with the deepest sympathy on the Zionist
movement our deputation here in Paris is
fully acquainted with the proposal
submitted yesterday by the Zionist
Organization to the peace conference and
we regard them as moderate and proper we
will do our best insofar as we are
concerned to help them through we will
wish the Jews a most hearty welcome home
I look forward and my people with me
look forward to a future in which we
will help you and you will help us so
that the countries in which we are
mutually interested may once again take
their places in the community of the
civilized peoples of the world but he
did throw on this caveat he was doing
this because he wanted their support for
an independent state and he did throw on
the caveat look this only applies I'm
only supportive essentially of the
Balfour Declaration if we get our
independent state so he really wanted he
really wanted an independent independent
state and he explicitly said hey look we
don't get an independent state all the
stuff I said here
doesn't doesn't really apply and so you
end up with the Treaty of sev in 1920
and it turns out that that the
sykes-picot agreement held a lot more
weight than the assurances between
McMahon and Hussein because in the
Treaty of sev this area was divided
essentially according to the sykes-picot
agreement up here this whole region was
given to France they called it a mandate
which is essentially it was allowed to
be occupied by France but they called a
mandate to the Allies wanted to be
called a mandate so it didn't look like
France was getting something a mandate
is kind of hey you have to come help
these people to transition them to
establish a state to help them
transition institutions so eventually
they can get independence the the Allies
wanted it to appear that look look look
Central Powers look Ottomans you're not
giving us something you're not giving us
his territory you're giving us you're
giving us a responsibility but needless
to say they were eager to occupy this
territory so eager that when fassold bin
Hussein in 1920 declared himself king of
Syria they booted him out and he was in
really no power to to kind of contest
that booting out this area right over
here and this was pretty much in line
with the sykes-picot agreement became a
British this whole area right over here
became a British Mandate now in in what
is now Iraq you essentially have an
uprising in 1920 they don't they don't
appreciate they thought that they were
going to become independent now they
were free of the Ottomans but now all of
a sudden the British come and come in
and say that they're in charge so you
have this revolt against the British in
1920 the British start to realize gee
this is kind of expensive trying to try
to keep control of this
maybe we should we should install
someone when and we'll still kind of
keep this as a protectorate as a
mandated territory but we should why
don't we install someone who
an Arab leader as the king of this
region and so they install fassl bin
Hussein as a king of Iraq and he is a
king of Iraq essentially under
protection or under influence of the
British from 1921 until 1933 and that's
when they finally get independence of of
the British in 1932 now when they get
booted out of Syria his brother Abdullah
son of Hussein bin Ali he's allowed to
become king of Transjordan and they
later get independence in 1946 after
World War 2 at which point he becomes
the king of Jordan Syria and Lebanon
they don't get independence until during
or after World War 2 Lebanon gets
independence in 1943 Syria gets
independence from the French in 1946 and
we know that the Mandate of Palestine
which the British kept this would
continue to be a sore point through
World War two too and then with the
establishment of the State of Israel
shortly afterwards it becomes a very I
guess we could say hot point in
international affairs